what's fair about it we are pond finna
team and welcome to another episode of
challenge confited this is the series
where you've challenged us with your
craziest ideas related to table things
we'll go through all of your comments
pick the most creative ones to make a
video if you're ready I get to lick my
feet treat and give you the shout out so
make sure to leave your ideas and
comment section pillow just quickly
before we started with the first
challenge will likely say that we have
now created a patreon page that some of
you advised us to do so now you can go
support us on the patreon page was some
extra content probably some bloopers and
other stuff and we'll also try to be
very interactive on the page so there is
a link in the description and you can go
check it out there but now let's move to
the first challenge William Stewart
wants to make an around nature with the
edge of the paddle this should be no
problem
[Music]
[Applause]
next up Daniel Tron wants to play with
the mobile phone and do an around the
neck shirt I have a feeling this going
to be a good brackets let's see
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
as I figured this is a good racket let's
see how many are on the net shops
I can make dr. Debbie threaten to stock
up stock wants us to make weekly
consecutive errands back shots let's see
how it goes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so our friend Briscoe wants us to build
a card house and spin the ball around in
it and between the cards I farted out
with normal playing cards but they
weren't big enough so I bought this
extra large playing cards and I'm gonna
build the card house with beast and see
how it goes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
monterrico wants to play table tennis
with a frying pan since I started with
the knife last time I let you start with
the frying pan this time let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mara kovarsky wants to play 15 seconds
with two balls and we'll have to turn
around and switch hands after each shot
what will you get TC easily well I
haven't done this kind of stuff in a
long time so we'll see well I get dizzy
very easily so this is probably going to
feel horrible but let's try it out but
will first try out with only turning
around and then if it goes well we'll
switch hands also
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that went quite well and we are still on
our feet so let's try with that
switching hands also
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
thanks for watching guys if you enjoyed
this extra episode make sure to leave it
a thumbs up and check out the patreon
page in the link in description if
you're new to the channel subscribe here
and watch the previous episodes here
until next time